pour ce moment lien grands projets d'ici
le mois prochain nous devons faire une
tournée internationale en destination de
ces pays pour représenter dignement la
martinique et la commune de basse pointe
à travers cédant sa culture et sa
tradition et surtout le patrimoine
martiniquais et la situation financière
économique de l'association
l'association rencontrent des
difficultés financières par rapport à ce
voyage parce que nous avons eu
l'occasion de faire trois grands
spectacles et la population a répondu
favorablement mais grâce à ses sous nous
avons plus quand même payer toute la
partie européenne concernant
l'hébergement nourriture transport et
pourquoi je fais je parle de cette
difficulté et je fais appel à la
générosité la générosité de la
martinique
notre peuple martiniquais c'est parce
que pomme cannelle a besoin de deux
montants de 32000 euros pour financer
les billets d'avion de martinique par y
aller retour et direction bruxelles
aussi et un séjour de dix jours à
l'hôtel pour héberger les quarante
danseurs danseuses et musiciens
voilà le travail que vous faites dans la
culture n'est pas reconnu le travail
reconnu de la deux le travail les pommes
cannelle reconnu et aussi la culture
martiniquaise
mais je vais dire quand même qu'il n'est
jamais suffisant de de promouvoir une
culture celle ci on n'a pas de fonds
comme cannes elle ira dans une tournée
internationale et à l'échelon bien sûr
dans de plus grandes envergures donc il
y aura quand même sept pays a sillonné
on fera la suisse l'italie l'espagne le
portugal
il y aura la roumanie on va ici aussi la
france la belgique donc il ya encore
d'autres pays par contre si on ne
réussit pas à collecter ces fonds on
sera obligé de fait la moitié de la
tournée c'est la première fois que vous
êtes dans cette situation au niveau de
pomme cannelle on dit un début à tout
depuis 38 ans que la compagnie de danse
pom'kanel existe si la première fois
effectivement que nous nous trouvons
dans cette de telles situations et je
vais pas dire que c'est de notre faute
ou la faute de quiconque mais il y a un
problème quelque part c'est simplement
parce que nous n'avons pas pu quand même
récolté suffisamment de fonds durant
toute l'année parce que c'est le
pour payer nos billets d'avion et c'est
la récompense des danseurs lorsqu'ils
sont surtout talent en train de danser
pour pomme cannelle et puis c'est
l'heure l'objectif final de pomme
cannelle durant une année
ces deux de récompenser les danseurs et
danseuses à travers une tournée
européenne